if we include both the Old Testament and
the New Testament the Bible is written
in three languages Hebrew Aramaic and
Greek the Old Testament or the Hebrew
Bible is 99 written in Hebrew the
language of the ancient Israelites of
course it's Biblical Hebrew which is
somewhat different from Modern Hebrew
but not that different the other one
percent is written in biblical Aramaic
the Jews who were taken into captivity
by the Babylonian Empire learned Aramaic
and the Aramaic sections of the Bible
were written during that time or shortly
after Aramaic is a Semitic language
closely related to Hebrew if you can
read Biblical Hebrew it's not that hard
to learn to read biblical Aramaic though
you do have to learn it the New
Testament was written in koine Greek the
form of Greek which was used as a lingua
Franca throughout the Eastern
Mediterranean when Judea was under Roman
control the writers of the New Testament
spoke Aramaic or Hebrew as their native
language but they probably wrote in
Greek so that their writings would reach
a much wider audience that's why